[Music]  of course with the latest government  crisis all the pundits and Talking Heads  on cable news channels have had so much  to work with so much to talk about but  remember they don't just do a lot of  talking on cable news they also do a lot  of listening  so here ladies and gentlemen is our  tribute to those unsung heroes the  listeners on cable news  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  my fellow Guardsmen on the cable news  article pretty Congress mysterious  really bad listen listen  [Music]  that's nice  I hear you got a lot in there right a  lot of that way you were in there a lot  weren't you Pender give me a listening  on the cable news what were you doing  yeah  [Applause]